yesterday the newest Supreme Court
justice Neal Gorsuch heard his first
case since being sworn in and this is
interesting
true story even though he's now
performing official duties he's Supreme
Court justice he is still the lowest
judge on the totem pole which means true
story he's forced to perform a low-level
job such as heading up the cafeteria
committee and opening doors for the
other judges this is a real thing they
do I know it sounds crazy it's all part
of a long-standing tradition of hazing
the newest justice this has been going
on it's been going on for years here's a
look at the other degrading things
Gossage has to endure it's pretty
amazing he's has to give the other
justices pedicures he's made to wear an
embarrassing robe in public he's
braiding Justice Kennedy's signature rat
tail he has to act as a human backboard
in their weekly pickup game taking a
hint from a bond shaped like Lady
Justice that's one of the things you
have to do he has to drive Lissa's drive
the getaway van while the other justices
rob a jewelry store and finally the calm
customer finally there he is having some
steak for lunch no wait a minute he's
just feeding it to the other justices in
their giant
you
you